SPEAKER: Welcome to the
talk by Betsy Teutsch on 100
for $100-- or, sorry.
100 under $100: One Hundred
Tools for Empowering Women--
Global Women.
And she gives a
comprehensive look
at effective and
low-cost solutions
for helping women in the
global south out of poverty.
Most books on the subject
focus on one problem and one
solution, but Teutsch shares
100 successful proven paths out
of poverty in 11
different sectors
in a visually striking
book full of images
of vibrant, strong women.
The book is available
in paperback,
and we have a number of copies
here for anybody who wants one.
They're free of charge.
And with that, I give
you Betsy Teutsch.
BETSY TEUTSCH: Thanks so much.
It's really great
to be at Google.
Before I launch into telling
you about these tools in front
of me that are
both a combination
of low-tech and high-tech,
but they're all high impact,
I wanted to just have kind
of a love letter to Google
and tell you how often
an author of any type
uses Google as search when
you're trying to verify things
as you go along in writing.
But in my book in
particular, because it
was heavily photographic, there
were a lot of Google features
that made it possible.
Really, I couldn't
have done this book
without Google Image search.
It just was phenomenal.
And sometimes I would
be looking for a picture
that I know I'd seen, which
is incredibly frustrating.
I got better at keeping track
of pictures that I liked,
but sometimes I
didn't realize that I
was going to want that
particular picture,
and then I would have to
use a million tag words
and try to find it.
And then Google Image,
and then scroll down,
and there it would be.
Because the book is printed,
I needed very high resolution
photographs.
So I really liked
the tool that I
could go in and
specify that I was only
searching for large photos.
That was super helpful.
And then I discovered
the feature
where you can click on an image
and move it up to the search
box, and that is super cool.
You can then-- it shows you
a lot of different places
that that image
appears, and then
I could go through and
find-- sometimes it
led me to places where
I could find more
information about the image.
Because a lot of times,
an image on a website,
you can't tell
where it came from.
And I needed permission for
all the pictures in the book,
so I had to track it
down to the source,
and that was really challenging.
Also, the book, I was
tracking 100 different tools,
and I needed in 11 sectors.
So I had all these
Google spreadsheets,
and I could color
code everything
and figure out how it all laid
out just with a visual scan.
But then as I added tools, it
kept getting bigger and bigger,
and then I couldn't
maneuver until I
learned about freezing rows.
I mean, this might
be old hat to you,
but to somebody that comes
in from a different field,
I was like, wow.
That is so smart.
I can't believe somebody
thought of that.
But it made the whole
thing absolutely possible.
So what I want to focus on
today is the information
communication
technology section,
which is six different
tools that I included.
And the first challenge
of this section
was, how do you
subsume ICT, which
has transformed
the entire world,
into a 500-word essay
and then six tools?
I mean, it was
hugely challenging.
So I started out with the
primary tool, which to me seems
to be literacy in general.
Because ICT is not
very useful if people
have no reading ability.
It also is challenging
if the language is not
their native
language, but that's
another question that Google is
addressing through Translate.
And I do use that often
when I'm going to a website
and it's in Spanish or
Chinese or something.
And I'm very grateful for that.
Literacy is really
the foundation.
And the foundational tool
in the developing world,
as many of you might
know, is cell phones.
Does anybody
remember back to when
you had a cell phone like this?
It was how many years
ago, do you think?
AUDIENCE: 10?
AUDIENCE: 15?
BETSY TEUTSCH: I would
say probably more like 15.
This is a Nokia 1100, and
I bought this on eBay.
It cost $20.
Imagine that a 15-year-old
cell phone has a resale value.
It was the best-selling
cell phone in the world.
They sold about 250
million of them.
And it really meets
the design factors
or the factors in
general that make
a tool popular in
the developing world.
And it really upended
thinking about how to help
people who are impoverished.
The people that we call the
bottom of the pyramid, people
that live on $1 a
day, there are a lot
of terms for the world's
poorest seventh or eighth.
It's like one-- the world's
poorest billion people.
So they live without
infrastructure of electricity,
they don't have
sanitation infrastructure,
no running water.
And obviously, things
like cell phones
don't do you much good
without electricity.
But the proliferation of the
cell phone has been phenomenal.
And there was a book
about 15 years ago,
maybe 10, called "The Fortune
at the Bottom of the Pyramid."
And it was by an
economist named Prahalad,
and what he was pointing
out was that there
are business opportunities
among the world's poorest.
That if you think of poor people
as customers, not as charity
cases, there are many ways
that you can design things
that people will want.
And it was kind of a
capitalist argument.
He wasn't really a
philanthropist or a do-gooder.
He was just telling people that
there are a lot of business
opportunities.
And when I looked back
at the book, most of them
are no longer
particularly relevant.
And it was before the cell
phone had really taken off.
So it really did prove his
case that if you could design
something that was-- that
meant a number of criteria,
it could be very successful.
So the first is that it has
to solve a problem that people
perceive they have.
One of the problems, for
example, with water filtration
is that in a lot of places,
people don't know germ theory,
and they don't know that
their water is causing
them to be ill, and that the
water-borne diseases come
from pathogens in the water,
because you can't see them.
So teaching people
how to purify water
when they are unconvinced
that that needs to be done
is a hard sell.
Getting people telephones
that never had them
was an easy sell.
It is well designed.
That's very crucial.
You need things
to be attractive.
And there's just something
about this little handheld, cute
telephone that everybody
loves intuitively.
It also has a lot
of extra features
that are particularly compelling
for people in the developing
world.
One is that when I press
this button, it lights.
And if I press it twice,
the light stays on.
And for people who were
using flashlights and having
to buy batteries all the time,
this was incredibly convenient.
And you can think of all
the other functionalities
that even a really basic
cell phone like this has,
such as texting
and a calculator.
I've been in the
developing world trying
to communicate with a
vendor, and we've just
brought up our calculators.
[LAUGHTER]
Negotiated back and forth.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what do
people do to charge them?
BETSY TEUTSCH: Well, you
raise an extremely important
question.
There has always
been an interest
in getting people electricity
in the developing world.
And people can--
sometimes they siphon off
electricity from a
grid, but the grids
are pretty unreliable
to begin with.
People use batteries, but
they don't help very much
with the cell phone, because
you need to plug it in.
They have generators and they
can run electricity that way.
But cell phones have
been a huge driver
of the demand for electricity.
So one of the things that
I wanted to talk about
was the way that these
tools are integrated.
One thing brings another.
And so that the cell
phone, people now
are reading books
on cell phones.
They've gotten a little more--
obviously over the years,
we've added more functionality.
And I'm going to get
back to your question.
But I did want to say
that we decided not to do
a photographic show today.
But if anybody wants to
quick Google freedom241.com,
you can see that there
is a smartphone that just
went on the market in India.
Anybody-- this is a dumb phone?
This is called a feature phone.
Does anybody want to
guess how much the Freedom
241 is going to cost?
AUDIENCE: $4.
BETSY TEUTSCH: $4.
Had you already-- did
you know that already?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
BETSY TEUTSCH:
Did you design it?
[LAUGHTER]
$4.
I don't think there are
any reviews out yet.
But I mean, the drop
in prices is amazing.
And just for the
record, just background,
in the developing world,
you don't typically
have a cell phone plan.
You buy the phone, and
you buy different ones.
Some of them have radios.
They have all different
kinds of things in them.
And they just keep
buying them used.
This isn't made anymore,
but I'm sure you can still
buy them in the market.
And people buy minutes.
They insert a card.
So the big rush to the
bottom, the big price
wars in the developing world
are the price-- the cost
of minutes, cell phone minutes.
So that also means
that people don't
have a reliable cell phone
number at the entry level.
Because once you get a new
card, you get a new number.
So they use cell phones
very differently.
And I mentioned that electricity
is the next challenge.
People have always
wanted electricity.
And lights would be
the primary thing
that you would want
electricity for.
But as I've been researching
this whole field,
it seems to me that
cell phone charging is
driving the demand for lights.
So I have a bunch of
different lights here.
The key to cheap lighting that
is improving what they have,
which is kerosene lamps,
which is-- kerosene
is a fossil fuel and
dirty, and it's usually
subsidized by governments
kind of perversely.
And the emissions are
really toxic for people
at home, which are primarily
the women and children.
This is an LED light.
And because solar panels have
gotten so much more efficient,
this is actually
the solar panel.
This is what you need to charge.
You leave it out during the
day, and then at night you
get eight hours of light.
If you need the light to extend,
this is the lower wattage.
If you need it-- if
you want it brighter,
if you can waste all your
charge, you can do it that way.
And also they've-- because this
is marketed both in the rich
world and the poor world or the
fat world and the lean world,
as some people call it, there
are flashers to make it useful
to you to have in your cars,
an emergency like if you need
to flag down help.
This is called the MPOWERD.
MP-- it's the Luci.
I like that name.
And here are some--
here's another design.
This is kind of
the next level up.
This is the solar
charging panel.
It's a little bit bigger.
And it has your lower
wattage and a task light.
It has higher wattage.
And cell phone charging.
So this is the kind of thing
that has huge appeal to people.
It's a little bit
more expensive,
but part of the pricing
programs for these
is that if you buy something
like this for $10--
it's around that price, and
there are many, many versions
of this in the developing
world-- you no longer have
to purchase kerosene.
So eventually, there
is a price point
at which what you
didn't spend on kerosene
has paid for the lamp.
You need help getting over the
hurdle of buying it up front,
either through a loan or--
most likely through a loan.
But even with interest,
you still come out ahead.
And then you have a solar lamp.
You own it.
And it provides three times the
light that you previously had,
and you've gotten rid of
all the smoke in the house.
Another thing that
cell phones are driving
is reading and literacy.
Because if you want
to text, you need
to know how to spell and write.
And it's also driving an
interest in eyeglasses.
There are a huge number of
people in the world that
have never checked their eyes.
Because if you don't
know that there
is a simple,
inexpensive correction,
you wouldn't think to do that.
And even the most basic readers
now cost just a few dollars.
They come from China.
They're really cheap.
There are a number
of social businesses
that focus on getting
glasses to people.
And people's productivity
is hugely enhanced.
The rate of-- the return
on investment for glasses
is something like seven to one.
If a craftsman can't see what
she's doing as she gets older,
and then she gets readers,
she's way more productive.
Schoolchildren, about
10% of schoolchildren
need eye correction.
And of course, you
might have known people
or been one of them that
sit in the classroom
and don't know what's going
on because you can't actually
see it.
So these cute little glasses
are called OneDollarGlasses.
And they were created by a
physics teacher in Austria.
And their idea is to
get the cheap lenses
from China-- most cheap
things come from China--
and then he created a machine.
And just the raw material,
which is this really light wire,
and the machine-- they teach
people how to mechanically
make the glasses on site.
And you get to pick
what color bead you
want to kind of
personalize it a little.
And they are so light that
they don't need eye pads.
So that gets you to
one of the design
concepts of designing
things that are
for the bottom of the pyramid.
To make them frugal, to
make them affordable,
you have to engineer them in
a way that is stripping down
in essentials.
That means that they have
fewer parts that will break,
fewer parts that need to
be accessed to begin with,
but it still needs to work.
So this is a great
example to me of ingenuity
and frugal engineering.
I'm going to pass it around
if you want to see them.
So these products
need to be attractive,
they need to be frugally
engineered, they need to work.
That's really essential.
People in the
developing world have
had a lot of experience
with things that don't work.
So if you add warranties and
you give people more confidence
that if something fails,
they have recourse,
then the adoption
rate goes way up.
Because a big part
of the problem
is not that we don't
have solutions,
it's that we don't have
good implementation
of the solutions.
So in some cases,
market distribution
is far more effective than
trying to just give things
to people.
People don't particularly
appreciate things
that are just given to them.
And if you just give people
things, the designers of them
are not accountable for how
they're going to be used.
I wanted to show you
another way that literacy
is expanding around the world.
And this is just
basically a reader.
I just put up on
my Facebook page,
does anybody have a dead reader?
Because I wanted a sample.
This company is
called Worldreader.
And Worldreader has the mission
of getting reading material out
to schoolchildren.
And they distribute a
package to a school that's
underwritten by--
this is underwriting
because it's education.
You can't expect
kids to pay for it.
But they have--
the schoolteachers
get to pick the content
for their school.
Half is in English, half is
in their native language,
wherever they are.
And the system comes with a
box with all these readers
and a big solar charging panel.
And as you might know yourself,
a Kindle or whatever kind
of reader you have holds a
charge for a really long time.
They are stripped down
intentionally for that purpose.
They don't have a lot of
other functions on them.
So the energy goes towards
bringing up the material.
So a kid who never had
any access to books,
now she has a library
that she can bring home
every night with a couple
hundred books in it.
And they get some-- they
can elect a couple too
from the system.
And I'm happy to say that my
book is-- they have uploaded
it, so that's exciting.
I can look in on
the metrics and see
who's opened my book
and what country
and how many pages they've read.
And it doesn't tell you
if it had any impact.
That is the trouble
with statistics.
But it's an amazing setup.
And these are
backlit, so that also
gets over the hurdle of not
having electric lights at home,
or any lights really, because
it brings its own light.
It's very, very effective.
So I wanted to show
you another way
in which the internet and
the exchange of information
is impacting how ideas
move around the world.
Our original thought was that we
are the center of the universe,
and everything comes
from Cambridge or MIT
out to the world from
the global north.
But in fact, a lot of ideas are
originating in the global south
where people have
the-- necessity
is the mother of invention.
So because people need
things, they figure them out.
So one thing that's incredibly
frustrating for anybody
in any kind of a workshop is
having an unreliable electrical
grid.
So a guy, Alfredo
Moser in Argentina,
had this problem
just browning out,
or the lights just went off in
his little factory warehouse
often, and he just
couldn't work.
So it wasn't that he
couldn't work his machines.
It was that he couldn't see
because there were no lights.
So he figured out that if
he put a hole in the ceiling
and then he put a light
in, just a plastic bottle
and filled it with water-- this
one is not filled with water--
but filled it with water, and
then cut a hole, stuck it up,
the light refracts through
the water, and in daylight
gives about the equivalent
of 60 watts of light.
And it does that without
any electricity at all.
It's just natural light.
It's kind of like a light
tunnel or a skylight,
but the water adds to
the refractory effect.
So this was such a
simple and great idea
that it, through
various websites,
just kind of went
around the world.
So it really took off
in the Philippines.
And it's taken off in South
Africa and many other places.
It's only helpful
during the day,
but still, free
light during the day
is a lot better than sitting
in the dark or with a lamp.
And so I call this global south
to global south transmission
of ideas.
Some of you might like
websites like Appropedia,
or there are all these how
to do it-type websites.
So if you look up
solar light bulb,
you'll see dozens of different
ways and directions and slides.
And most of them
don't rely on text.
So if people in a
different part of the world
know how to find
them, and even if they
don't have good literacy or even
if they're not literate at all,
it's just images.
They can figure out
how to make things.
So the internet has been a
fabulous way of spreading ideas
around the world.
And I'm sure will continue to be
so, only more so going forward.
The way that this all
impacts women is women
have been pretty marginalized
in most patriarchal cultures,
probably all, from
tools and technology.
And it's great to be in
the Ada Lovelace hall.
I was last week
at the Commission
on the Status of Women
at the United Nations,
and I saw a movie that
featured Ada Lovelace.
It's called "CODE:
Debugging the Gender Gap."
And it's about the challenge of
the absence of women in tech.
Not that you would know
anything about that.
And this is a way-- the
internet and all these tools,
once women can get
them, is a way for them
to kind of circumvent the
gatekeepers, the men that
would sort of think that they
shouldn't know this stuff
or have any access.
And it isn't
necessarily that women
think they shouldn't
have access to it.
It's because when you've
been denied access,
you think that you somehow
couldn't figure it out.
It's way too complicated.
Only men can do
this kind of thing.
And when women
realize and understand
and through keeping
girls in school
that these are neutral
tools and girls are just
as good at working
them as boys are,
it begins to be an equalizer.
I'm going to stop talking
and see if anybody
has questions or comments.
AUDIENCE: How were the
instructions for the light sort
of transferred?
I mean--
BETSY TEUTSCH:
Well, they usually
do it with a series of slides.
They take pictures.
And of course, that's
the other great thing.
Just so many cell phones
now have video capacity.
And I mean, not everybody
is stuck at this level.
That's the entry level.
Slides and videos, people upload
videos from all over the world.
It's just amazing.
And they try to break them down.
And then if you go to a
bigger site like Appropedia,
I think they have, like, 2,000--
200,000 pages or something like
that.
And people, if you
need a translation,
you just post you need
somebody to translate it,
and people will do that.
So the visuals and slideshows
are the most effective.
And now I just
discovered Google Slides.
You can even use Google
to do a slideshow.
People use kind of the
same tools everywhere.
And it's just so-- what I loved
about this research was just
seeing all the ingenious and
innovative ways that people
adapt ideas to their
local situation.
A guy in South Africa took
this idea and he thought, well,
why don't we combine it
with the LED charging?
So he came up with a product
that is called the Lightie.
And they usually use
a two-liter bottle.
This is just a smaller
version for demo purposes.
And he wrapped a solar
charging panel around it
so that you get free-- without
blocking the top light--
so you get free
light during the day,
and then I don't
know how it turns on.
I don't know where
the switch is.
But then you get light
at night as well.
I presume that he has some
kind of a shield or something,
because you can't turn it
off, unlike an electric light.
Once it's on, it
would just be on.
So I don't-- but people
combine these tools.
The last tool that I was
going to tell you about
was integrating a whole
bunch of different tools
in really cool ways.
So they now-- solar panels
have dropped in price,
and they're more efficient.
So a solar panel that used to
be this big is now this big.
And it used to cost that much,
and now it costs this much
and gives the same output.
So people can have
individual products
like this that are
solar charging,
but then they have to remember
to put them out every night.
And if they forget, they
don't have light the next day.
You know, people are people.
So having a solar panel that
just sits there and charges
is obviously going
to be more effective,
and give you enough
for many lights.
And then the lights
are plugged in.
They're not portable lights.
They're attached.
And the charging and
other small appliances.
A tablet, people are
starting to have tablets.
There's a $40
computer now in India.
So even the poorest
of the population
now has a lot of
things, a lot of devices
that they have to charge.
So combining microfinance,
which is small lending,
and cell phone, then you
can in some countries,
particularly Kenya-- Kenya
is in the forefront of what
we call mobile money,
using your cell
phone to send money,
which obviates the need
to have a checking account.
You just have money
in your-- it's money
that you send around
electronically.
It's kind of like Venmo,
but on a massive scale.
About 70% of Kenyans,
rich and poor,
use-- it's called-- M-Pesa
is what it's called.
So you can make a monthly or
weekly payment for yourself,
for your solar panel.
They install it.
You have to just put
a down payment down.
Then you make regular
payments via cell phone,
which lowers the
transaction cost enormously.
Part of what makes
microfinance expensive
is that the loan officer
goes around and, like,
picks up everybody's cash.
And he or she goes by bike.
I mean, you can imagine.
You've gotta pay that
person for their time.
This way, joop!
It's paid for.
And then after a set
number of payments--
it's usually a year
and a half of payments
that are set-- then your
solar panel is unlocked,
and you own it.
And then for the rest of the
life of the solar panel, which
is long.
Can be 25-- we don't
even know how long
they last, because we
haven't tested that yet.
You essentially have
free electricity,
except for maybe having
to replace the battery.
So it's integrating cell phone,
microfinance, mobile money,
and the product, and getting
it to people that need it.
So some more comments
or questions?
AUDIENCE: So you can get off
the grid with a solar panel.
What do you do-- how do
we deal with connectivity?
I would assume that
there would always
be the possibility that,
especially if there's
a single network provider,
that they would take a monopoly
position and charge too much.
BETSY TEUTSCH: Well,
there are a lot
of people working on
this problem, including
Mark Zuckerberg.
There's something
called internet.com.
They're running into a lot
of resistance in India,
trying to make internet kind
of like a human right Wi-Fi,
that you should be
able to access it.
What people in poor countries
do is go to internet cafes.
It's very cheap, and it
becomes kind of a social hub.
People in many places haven't
gotten to cell phones.
I mean, we can romanticize.
There are more people
in the world that
have cell phones than toilets.
That's true.
But there are a couple
of billion people
that don't have toilets.
So it's a little bit
of a cheat to make
that-- to trot out that
statistic, amazing as it is.
A lot of people are still
really relying on radio.
Radio is a very effective ICT
tool, and it's hyper local.
So in places that
no-- that don't yet
have access to the internet,
they rely on radio.
I'm not sure how the
connectivity works.
It's different
country to country.
And obviously, there are a
lot more networks in cities
than in remote areas.
But I would say that
there are probably very
few places on Earth that have
never seen a cell phone by now.
I don't know what's
going to happen when
they have the $4 smartphone.
They have a lot of apps.
They preload them
with a lot of things.
And what-- I think for
end users like myself,
I'm constantly confused
about what's in the cloud
and what's in my phone and
what's coming from where.
When I've gone abroad and
turned off my-- gone on airplane
mode-- you know, I was
in London and I did that,
and, like, I'm walking along,
and all of a sudden, my phone
starts pinging.
You know, like 10
texts came through
because I walked through a spot
that had Wi-Fi or something.
We're in this sort of
transitional state.
I imagine eventually
the globe will
be-- you can just get
internet from anywhere,
but we're not close to that.
AUDIENCE: Could you
just talk a little bit
about what motivated
you to write this book,
and what you're hoping to have
happen after having written
such a book?
BETSY TEUTSCH: Well,
what a great question.
I was tremendously
excited the more
I learned about these really
impactful, really smart, really
affordable tools.
And I felt like there's so
much bad news out in the world.
And most people, when you say
that two billion people live
on $1 to $2 a day,
it's just overwhelming.
It just sounds so dismal
and impossible that there's
anything that we can do.
And in fact, there
are so many people
working on really great things.
I was just over this
morning at the D-Lab at MIT.
And that focuses--
it's a design lab,
and it focuses on
using our design skills
to improve people's lives.
I also came in from
a feminist side
and really wondering, like,
who's paying attention
to the women that are kind
of blocked out of the design
process, out of
the supply chain?
They're not that
active in the-- a lot
of women in the developing
world can't make
their own financial decisions.
Their husbands decide what's
going to be spent on them.
Children can't make
their own decisions.
Their dads decide if they
stay in school or not.
So I really felt like focusing
on what women were doing,
and how women could more own
this sector or this connection
of technology, and
what will empower
them would be very important.
So I went searching for images.
I didn't start looking
to write a book.
I really just wanted
to gather information
about how women were
engaging technology
to have good examples.
And I just found the
most amazing images.
And I guess Pinterest--
Pinterest isn't really
a competition for you.
It's just a complementary
social media.
But I started Pinterest
boards of various things
that I was finding,
and eventually
I just found so
many great images
of women really owning the
tools that they were designing.
A lot of them are the
engineers, but a lot of them
are people that are using them.
And so I thought, this is
a whole different narrative
about women in the
developing world.
Usually we see them
standing in line
in camps with emaciated
children and looking very--
they are often victimized.
That's part of the narrative.
But there is this vibrant,
developing world narrative
of women that are smart and
experienced and taking charge,
and joining women's
groups, and creating
a whole different
future for themselves
and for their families.
So that's how I got
started on the book.
And the book is a
very flexible tool.
And it could be used-- I
kind of imagine my reader
to be somebody like
myself, like a baby boomer
woman with a little time and
interest in sharing her better
fortune with the
rest of the world.
But it's turning out
that that's one segment.
I also have-- I'm working
with science teachers
to create a junior high and
high school science curriculum.
Turns out, everybody's been
scratching their heads about,
how do you get girls
interested in STEM?
And how do you prevent that
drop-off so that by the time
they could even think
about majoring in STEM
at college, that they
haven't already left?
And it turns out, one big
answer is that girls really
like to know that they
can do something that will
help and make a difference.
About more than half
of engineering programs
that focus on design for the
developing world are female.
So it's a great strategy
to show boys and girls
that meeting these
global challenges
is a way to not--
you're not just
sitting in a science class.
You're sitting in a
class that will help
you be able to do something.
So that is really exciting.
And I'm also finding
some traction
getting to organizations that
are sharing this on the ground
with people that live in places
where it's kind a cookbook.
They can look through
and find a couple
of things that seem
like it might really
work for them, that
they hadn't known about.
And that is very exciting to me.
AUDIENCE: I was
just going to say,
it looks as though
your book has a focus
mostly on women in rural areas.
And so do you think that by
and large, there aren't so
many problems in the
cities, or that they already
have the necessary tools?
BETSY TEUTSCH: I would say
that women are about equally
distributed between rural
areas, which we call remote,
last-mile areas, and slums.
The world is really
trending urban.
I looked in the book at,
what are the 20 largest
cities in the world?
And 19 of them are
in the global south,
and I had never heard of them.
And what you're talking
about a city-- I mean,
that's just because I
haven't traveled that much
in the global south.
But it wasn't like Tokyo.
When I grew up,
everybody said Tokyo's
the biggest city in the world.
Well, it's not.
So what these cities are, they
have a core with a developed
center, with a modern
infrastructure,
and then they have
enormous perimeter slums.
And they call them
shanty towns, favelas,
a lot of different names.
Depending where you live,
they have different names.
But South Africa's
are pretty famous.
And they don't have
infrastructure.
They don't have plumbing,
they don't have running water,
they don't have
electricity, they
don't have a municipal
system, so the kids
don't have public schools.
So anybody that wants
to access anything
has to just kind of figure
out how to make it up.
So that has huge impacts
on women as well.
And in some ways, it's easier to
improve women's lives in cities
because it's denser population.
If you want to have, say,
public health interventions,
it's much easier to
roll them out in a city
where it's not so
hard-- you know,
there are so many people there,
you can have more impact.
The challenge of really
remote areas is just,
how do you get the
information there,
but how do you get the
physical stuff there?
You know, the roads
are really bad.
That's why when
internet comes, it
does give people
access to things
that they didn't have before.
So it's interesting.
I do have a large section of
the book on smallholder farmers
and about-- in the developing
world, about 70% of the food
is grown by women.
So when you think of a
developing world farmer,
you don't-- a woman doesn't
pop up in your head.
You think of a man.
But that's actually-- and
that's because partly, the men
are trickling out to
cities and migrants
going around, working,
going to other countries
where they can work.
And often, the women
are left behind.
So I would say that
rural women are
kind of doubly disadvantaged.
They don't have
exposure to new ideas.
The traditions are
far more constraining.
And there's
patriarchal traditions.
And also, there is
still an incentive
to have more
children if you farm,
because you have more hands.
You have more mouths
to feed, but you
have more people to help out.
Whereas in the
city, women and men
alike have really
adopted family planning.
The family size has
plunged in one generation.
In Mexico, it was five children
per mother a decade ago--
I mean, a generation
ago, and now it's two.
That's why a lot of what
we're hearing about-- we
don't have that many people
coming from Mexico anymore.
They're coming through Mexico,
but they're not actually
Mexican.
So women in the cities are
more exposed to new ideas.
And one of those new
ideas is education
for girls and empowerment
and smaller families.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]